With this we have provided a basic mechanism
to record and replay arbitrary function calls
together with their values.
This mechanism, in general, allows to record arbitrary interaction between program parts,
as well as arbitrary interaction between the program and its environment.
But this is just a tiny slice of what can be done in record and replay.
Actually, while being pretty general, it's also pretty limited yet.
In particular, one could store the list of calls in a file
such that it can be reproduced at any time,
handle structured elements properly, that is, lists and maps,
record, and possibly replay, return values too.
Record global variables, or record only a subset of all calls.
Python makes recording and replaying function calls very easy.
Especially compared to compiled languages such as Java or C.
So feel free to toy around and expand this code.